right now man one of the most illest mcs
of all time what's up keV Fabolous
what's up keV yo man that set was lit
bro yeah man we went to a hope that we
would do mixtapes we went to the the old
classic joints he went to some loose
stuff and we went to young og project we
just went everywhere no what's crazy is
like September 11 2001 is an important
day for America but as a like 15 year
old hip-hop fan it was important day for
me cuz I went to the store I went to the
warehouse I bought the blueprint about
ghetto fabulous yeah man I told a story
Big Sean told me one time that on that
day too like he only had you know he he
only had enough money to buy one hour
and he told me that he bought me over
the blueprints keeping the gangster in
such an [__] on record yeah man that
was that was that was like you know you
know you had to do like those Street
cuts and it had to be like gritty and
but for sure that was from that era like
what you had to do that a moment in high
school for me thats Fabolous related
besides the very first professional
mixtape shoutout to DJ Clue
but your verse on the on the clips album
Lord willin Bravo and like I've had some
memorable memorable like lines and
verses man but you know sometimes when
you collaborate with guys that's you
that you really rock with man sometimes
you it makes it not only makes the
collaboration better but like it makes
you step up your game too because you
know I mean you know that's one of the
joints that people are gonna pay
attention to man and that's that was one
of those joints it's so loose in this
mixtape got announced oh I don't know if
it's gonna be a mixtape or album with
you and Jaden what is oh yeah man me and
Jada was just so he came to my party
Island Co double-a in Charlotte and you
know we just talked about doing a couple
things man and I'm gonna put out a whole
state project yeah we we we I want to do
it a mix it what we gonna we gonna do it
through iTunes too so that's what we did
you better get that check now I gotta be
able title to yeah yeah yeah title title
is the family minute so we got it we got
to work with Tyler listen
right now in New York there's a lot of
youngsters coming up you got the Joey
badasses you've got the Flatbush zombies
Bodega bands yeah Troy abs and recently
I'm trans one of my few friends in the
business I say right I mean that's my
brother and I know you guys work
together
you were like bricks in my backpack
three or two yeah man like only I worked
with or yeah because I met him I've met
him really in the streets you know I'm
saying and just uh you know that we
built our relationship from from there
and then it came about when actually
when I met him I didn't even know he ran
that's crazy like you know saying so I
just met him and we ended up clicking
and then he came out of nowhere talk
about he didn't he wrapped it he had
songs then I was like what like what
is your take I'd help him out as much as
he could on this Joey Troy because look
trust my dog but like you know the
Capital steez thing to me was over the
line but look you know it's one New
York's talking about so you you wanted
to keep to me it's like jayan nas and
then fab yeah what's your take I don't
know all of the specifics in it I don't
know all that what happened I heard Troy
respond and I heard that one of the guys
came at Troy was I really came at him
about his album sells or something like
that it you know so I don't really know
everything that happened really in it
you know saying I don't even know I know
people is going going crazy about
something that Troy said but I don't
even know all of he was serving of
Capital steez is Joey banis shout out to
my brother static Specter but capital
Steve's is Joey badasses
man who committed suicide a couple years
ago oh so Troy took a shot at him and
it's kind of like you know look at the
end of the day I respect Troy because he
put out a record in 2016 in a beef
nowadays this Instagram tweets right
there's a record out so shout out to
Troy but I'm just like you know the end
of the day New York is um it's kind of
like in a place where there's always new
york though is this is a competitive
sport there 100% Olympia shots at you
you know you gotta you gotta expect a
retaliation too by the way six year
anniversary and there is no competition
- right yeah man I put that up yesterday
man I didn't even know that man on some
target lost it like running around
shoutout I caught it about 11:00 p.m.
I was working at Best Buy as a senior in
high school what was the mixtape that
you put out in stores the blue that was
the cover that was that was all older
more street Dreams brah the more street
Dreams that was crazy - that's my
favorite project thank you obviously
it's that was crazy right there we put
there's no competition - as a EP as well
that's what you'll be killing up came
from and all you know like sometimes
I'll mix tapes like have performed so
well for me like we had to we had to do
something else with it like you know
saying the so tape series to me has been
like
one of the best things that like hip-hop
has had like yo like hidden Juke it's
very slept on is got three soul tapes yo
and all of them to the people who here
of our classics right Natalie had to put
people on like I said I might start
telling people like what people say the
old man slept on us on the red we'll put
somebody on that tape oh yeah put
somebody on who don't know I don't know
you know so you gotta shoot that what's
crazy is like I heard the plug record
that's probably one of my most played
record in iTunes now I'm a hip hop head
right but that record I love let me ask
you about the cadence of the record
because a lot of people are like yo it
kind of took the cadence of the Travis
Scott record oh okay yeah not me it's
definitely what it is it's a bit of
right now record so what Travis Scott is
record stops one of the things that he's
doing right now but a few years so a lot
of the influence this is that's around
you hear like different people or or
even just Travis Scott you can hear some
Kanye stuff and you get here some Travis
Scott influence in there or vice versa
and you know that's what I think is
really is a lot of different mazing
break and I'm never going to survive yo
sniffing look what you got yeah I just
got a because I know you got to go so at
one question cuz there is nobody that
kills the Jersey game like you young how
many closets do you actually have for
all your jerseys I actually got a
storage of storage facility and you just
have a few boxes at a storage facility
over like yo I gotta go get that uh that
Ryder Jersey you got I can't wear them
anymore you know in that era when I saw
exes yeah
like you know even the ones now we get a
week they're more fitted there's like
more to you stuff so I what I have been
doing is pulling some out and getting uh
getting the place to sign up and I get
on Frank Frank yeah so look doing the
well is amazing reckon we're playing it
at radio let everybody know when can we
get the next fab at one the next fab
projects is on the way man I'm digging
about even by the end of the month top
of April I had it I was trying to get it
out for Valentine's man I had a I had a
issue with uh with all my production
company and the labels it's too much
they even going to me but uh as soon as
it's clear that everybody out there go
download summertime shoot out probably
top mixtape of last year personally
thank you bro amazing project and yo man
fab appreciate your time brother always
he know brother yup mama appreciate you
thank you bro